foreign
I was abused by my stepmother verbally
emotionally and physically thankfully
not sexually hold on hold on there is no
thankfully here it's easy to pass along
to say hey it was emotional but it
wasn't this I want you to sit in the
hell that was your job
[Music]
what up what up what up this is John
with the Dr John deloney show and I'm so
grateful you've joined us
we are figuring it out whatever's going
on in your life and your marriage and
your relationships trying to date in the
20s what century are we in 21st in this
century
madness out there this is a Dr John
deloney show which we so creatively
titled after me I'm John and we are
talking mental health relationships
marriage parenting all the things that
are keeping us up struggling
um if you want to be on the show give me
a buzz
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 and don't forget to send
in your success stories
ways you've transformed your marriage
ways you transform your parenting uh
ways you have decided I'm not gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna set these backpack full
of bricks down of old childhood abuse
I'm gonna move on
let us know about your success stories
because we want to share them with the
world and don't forget to leave your
five star reviews and hit subscribe it
just takes like one second just hit
subscribe real quick ready
okay thank you for doing that one of one
or two of you probably did that just
then but probably not all right let's go
to Nico in Boise what's up Nico
good morning Dr John good morning Nico
what's up
well I have a problem that I've sought
resources for and basically the advice I
found on the internet is that the issue
I'm having makes me a wuss so I figured
I'd reach out to you and see if maybe
you could give me a little better advice
you were like I know it was I'll call
him well done Nico well done so what's
up man what's what's this problem you
got
well
hold on hold you by the way never go to
the Internet dude
thank you there you go I had to learn
that one the hard way go to random
podcasters way safer way safer all right
so what's up my wife speaks pretty
highly of you so I I figured that was a
good place to start you're a wise man
listening to your wise wife well done
okay so what's up
so as a child I was abused by my
stepmother verbally emotionally and
physically thankfully not sexually
um hold on hold on hold on hold on stop
you right there I'ma stop you through
this whole thing is that cool yeah okay
okay there is no thankfully here
okay okay
it's easy to pass along to say hey it
was emotional it was physical it was
psychological but it wasn't this as
though there's levels here
okay I want you to sit in the hell that
was your childhood
and don't say yeah but somebody else got
this and somebody else got the We're not
gonna do that we're gonna let it ride
cool
okay all right we're in it now we're in
it your stepmother abused you
evil person tell me more yeah all right
well so she was my primary caretaker and
parental figure my dad worked a lot
we're talking gone for weeks come home
for a few days gone again and so she was
my primary person and
I didn't really think much of it as a
kid it was just that was my normal but
then they got divorced when I was
getting ready to enter eighth grade
and
things happened I I didn't know about it
at the time but I had issues with women
especially when they would show any
emotion besides happiness I would shut
down
and I
only had a couple relationships through
High School nothing really serious and
then after high school
I again didn't realize it at the time
but looking back on I kind of avoided
interacting much with women like jumped
into male dominated professions and
basically became my father working all
the time and then
about two years ago
um
my wife who was one of the couple
relationships I did have in high school
she was my childhood sweetheart uh
we we reconnected after more than a
decade and ended up getting married and
we actually just on Valentine's Day had
had a daughter congratulations man
thank you
but through the course of our marriage
there's been a couple incidents where my
wife has had tension or conflict with
another woman
and I didn't defend her
and
basically I just kind of shut down and
I didn't stand up to the other woman and
it's it's a thing that I again at the
time didn't notice until we talked about
it and she pointed out to me that
she doesn't feel safe because I don't
defend her and it's interesting and it's
caused a lot of reflection on me because
if it was a dude no question I'm a
pretty big dude I used to fight like I
was I was a fighter I wasn't great I was
eight and six but I'm within 10 pounds
of my fight weight like I I'm confident
and capable willing to throw down at a
moment's notice with a man
but if a woman gets mad I shut down I
just I don't know what to do and in a
couple instances of reference rather
than try to intervene or stop the other
woman or get in the way I tried to
control my wife instead I was like honey
you need to calm down you need to do
this and
I I didn't help her and she has
expressed to me that now she feels
unsafe
and I will do anything I can to save my
marriage and I I gotta figure out how to
get over
my issues with women and be able to
stand up to a woman
that's the first time you ever said that
out loud
uh besides talking to my wife about it
before I made this call yeah yeah I just
want to applaud you for saying that out
loud that's hard
thank you
that's hard
you're not a coward you're not weak okay
cool thank you
and if you've listened to the show for
more than five minutes I'm not always
accurate but I never lie okay
so
your mom abused you
that's trauma right
yeah are you are you do you do you
acknowledge that
I do okay
so trauma is
can be a couple of things
it can be what you experience which is
abuse
it can also be
what should have happened what you
should have received as a child as a kid
then an adult withheld from you
okay that makes sense
that means your dad is involved in this
too
your dad left you man
yeah and you got a little boy in there
wondering why dad did you leave me
with this woman that I don't really know
to go through this
and where's birth mom
that's the way when I was three okay he
remarried when I was almost six okay
and I'm just gonna make up a story here
that might or might not be right but it
wouldn't surprise me
if he went all in on your birth mom
and she died
and he didn't have a plan B
and his body told him
uh we don't have a plan B but we're
never going to get hurt like that again
but he wanted companionship and he
wanted connection so he got remarried to
somebody and then he hit the road
you nailed it almost exactly he was
all in with my mother to the point of
uh working multiple jobs to afford a
lifestyle they couldn't really afford so
she could have everything they were
living in Hawaii and he was I mean all
the way down to not being a religious
man himself that never missed Sunday
mass because she was at about Catholic
and then when she passed
it it broke him yeah and so the man that
raised me was an alcoholic that worked
on the road a lot that's right
I need you to hear the layers here mom
dies at three
dad disappears in a bottle
dad disappears on the road dad gets
remarried to somebody who's abusive and
crazy
and Nico you got out
don't let anybody ever
ever
tell you that you're weak
whether you're not strong or you're a
wuss ever
and I don't care about your MMA record
okay
you got out
you hear what I'm saying
I did okay
now I think you're misguided and I'm
telling you that out of love okay okay
um
I've done a few things to a few events
with
um Jocko you know Jocko
I do the Navy SEAL guy is real tough
he's awesome he's a great guy behind
closed doors he's a great guy in front
of closed doors he's a great guy and
he's doing some good stuff
former Navy SEAL
and I'll never forget this as long as I
live
in my training I didn't have a record at
all my training for years with mma's
before you could get fights every
weekend it was impossible to get fights
um
I left MMA training infinitely less of a
hothead
I haven't been in an altercation since
I just decided I'm never doing that
again because it wasn't the end result
wasn't worth it
and I'll never forget this interview
with Jocko where somebody was asking him
about it and if you don't know Jocko's
multi-time black belt in Jiu Jitsu he's
a former Navy SEAL he lifts weights 24 7
365 he eats like bricks and iron for
breakfast
um
and somebody asked him okay so you're
walking with your wife and kids down the
streets of San Diego and some crazy
person runs out and tries to start
something with you what do you do
and Jocko said
well I guess I would grab my wife's hand
and
we'd walk across the street and go down
the other sidewalk
and the guy said what
you wouldn't defend your wife's honor
and Jocko said something that will stay
with me for the rest of my life
he said
if it takes me beating up some
low life on the streets
to prove that I honor my wife
I have failed her in every other facet
of our relationship
that's not where you show honor
and then he went on to say there's a
handful of men on planet Earth that can
defeat me in hand-to-hand combat and
they all do it for a living they're all
professional fighters
and if somebody steps to me in a bar I
will buy them a drink and wish them well
because they're clearly having a worse
day than I am I have a pretty good life
and I remember one time getting into
something in my wife thinking I was
defending my wife and she uh she may
have been my girlfriend at the time or
just early on in my wife
she told me I feel less safe
when you do that
so I want to challenge you
given my my life story
listen to what Joshua to say
it maybe if your wife's in an
altercation with another woman the
greatest smartest way you can love her
is to grab your wife's hand and get out
that throwing a punch at a woman or
defending yourself in front of women or
mouthing off at a woman is not the
greatest display of honor and integrity
and safety
the strongest thing to do is to take
your emotions and put them in your back
pocket and do the smart intelligent
thing it's going to allow you to wake up
the next day without somebody throwing a
bottle and smashing in the head that you
didn't see coming or waking up the next
day not in jail waking up next day with
a bunch of people filming what happened
and now you can't you're unemployable
because you beat up a theme you see what
I'm saying
yeah so
what happened in these situations that
you walked away from or you tried to get
your wife to settle down to where she
feels unsafe
uh the first one would have been she was
a couple months pregnant
and we were in Nevada visiting some
family and
she was in the restroom and there was a
an old lady that was waiting in line and
got impatient was knocking on the door a
bunch and her and my wife had a
brief
spat or whatever when my wife was
leaving the bathroom
and my mother-in-law was with my wife at
the time and I had been
elsewhere checking out the drink cooler
going to get my wife something to drink
her and the Mother-in-law headed
straight outside instead of coming over
to where I was so I went out to ask her
if she still wanted to drink and we went
back into the store and then the old
lady came up and started telling my wife
you know other people have problems too
and going off about something and she
got close enough to my wife that it made
my life very uncomfortable and so my
wife got real loud and they were going
back and forth and I was just like
dumbfounded that this was even happening
like
here's my wife having a borderline
yelling match with an old lady at a gas
station and so so Nico you're the one
that got put in an unsafe situation
what about the fact that I didn't defend
my pregnant wife
what in the world is your pregnant wife
doing getting in a fight with the old
woman who may have medical issues may
have mental health issues
may have some deranged sun in the car
with a gun why in the world is
this is like children you see what I'm
saying
and I felt very much that way at the
time you were your feelings were
accurate at the same time no I your
feelings were right I took her into that
situation to the gas station
she had headed outside I took her back
in there okay so you I did something
okay so you messed up
you can get back in the car and be like
whoa thought we could talk that one out
not talking that one out then the whole
thing's over we're moving down the road
okay okay
I have asked my wife on occasion don't
get me in a situation that I'm gonna get
myself killed because I will
and she is my wife is as calm as they
come and she's like trust me if that
happens that would be because you're an
idiot not because not because of me
okay
your Valor
and value to your wife
is not in confronting old women in gas
stations
okay
yeah
when we talked about that situation and
the other one afterwards
because there was one other one
involving a nurse uh at the hospital
after the baby was born and
again
uh
it was a verbal thing my wife was really
stressed out and the nurse rather than
suggesting things was telling her what
to do and my wife got all he did and
ended up
telling her you know you need to get out
of here I'll have you removed while this
was going on my wife was getting tense
rather than telling the nurse to go I
was telling my wife you need to calm
down you need to take some deep breaths
keep your blood pressure down okay and
let's back out of that situation for a
second
did y'all just have a new kid
yeah you know who thinks rationally in
those moments no humans on the planet
no one yeah no one
and so
there's got to be some Grace on both
sides
confronting a nurse in a hospital is
almost never The Right Move
and telling your wife you just had a
baby that quote unquote calm down that's
probably pretty dumb all right I
wouldn't say that and I regretted it
well and
asking your husband to beat up a nurse
in a that's dumb to see what I'm saying
the whole thing is being able to step
back 30 000 foot after an emotional
interaction and say whoa that guy heated
feel like we're having a
misunderstanding though John because she
never asked me to beat anybody up it was
more
when I asked her about what she expects
okay essentially in these situations she
wants me to get in between to be a
shield so that she has the option to
leave instead I try to put her in the
Box I try to control her and that's
where the problem is
I I feel safe enough with my wife that I
will tell her you need to calm down
versus some strange woman who's getting
emotional and I don't know what to do
about it that's the smart move
leave
oh okay okay
we can have the discussions we can have
the disagreements we can have the fights
and the frustrations when we're at home
and we're safe and no one's going to hit
us over the head with a bottle
but In the Heat of the Moment Sometimes
the best thing to do is I need you to
leave
has she ever grabbed you by the arm and
walked you out of a place because you're
a hot head probably
did your MMA coach ever do that
um say shut me down
on more than one occasion exactly it
happens it's a smart move people who
love us and take care of us because
sometimes we get heated and emotional in
the in the moment
yeah I think the bigger conversation
that you all need to have is this
when do you not feel safe
Nico
when your wife is standing eye to eye
nose to nose with another adult woman
jawing and yelling and people are back
and forth
you can say honey that makes me I've got
to get in the middle of that
please walk away
and she can tell you I don't feel safe
when someone's attacking her that's a
whole other conversation that's not
happening here
and more broadly speaking
whether this is related or not I don't
know man but whether it's related or not
your body understands
very deeply
that when somebody gets aggressive or in
your face particularly someone who
reminds your body of your stepmom I
don't want to paint that as all women
but as someone who reminds your body of
your stepmom
the safest thing to do is shut the
machine down shut it down
go to neutral back it down the whole
thing turn it off that's the safest bet
to get out of the situation
okay
and your your homework over the course
of your life this is a ongoing thing
is to number one make sure this sweet
little girl
always knows that Mom and Dad are in
control emotionally and physically
okay that y'all are safe
okay we're gonna break this cycle with
this young one
and see I'm I'm really glad you said
that because there is
an instant that was different than that
um my wife had a son from a previous
relationship who I've since adopted I
mean that is he's my boy
but there was an instant one incident
with a man and it basically involved
my son and his son were at a park and
the other guy's kid was being a jerk to
my kid my kid said stop the kid didn't
stop
and uh my wife who at the time was my
girlfriend like we've been dating a
couple of days
um
went to talk to the other kid and
the dad got up in my wife's face and
started yelling at her and at the time
like I said girlfriend of a couple days
and I see a dude bigger than me yelling
at a woman smaller than me and I had no
issue getting between them and telling
him he needed to get the hell back
and but do you see the difference there
yeah it was a man no no no has nothing
to do with the gender I mean maybe it
does
but one of those situations or two of
those situations was escalated by your
wife
she could have got out of the bathroom
with an elderly woman and said hey I'm
sorry you're an older lady I'm sorry I
had to go you clearly have to go to I'm
sorry just walk away go home
that's different then
a big man coming at your wife in the
park in attack mode that's a totally
different proposition
and in your body it's starting to
conflate
aggression and frustration and all of it
just gets wound up
yes I would do the same thing if
someone's coming after my wife I'm gonna
get between them there's no question
about that
and if my wife just needs to if we can
just walk out the door and get in the
car I'm gonna walk out the door and get
in the car
and it's not because I'm a wimp but it's
not because it's because I'm smart and I
have honor that woven into my
relationship
as I was saying a minute ago you gotta
the rest of your life is going to be
dedicated to letting this little girl
know you're present you're not going to
get on the road you're not going to run
you're not going to turn to alcohol
wouldn't be an apparent gets hard and
make no mistake Nico it'll get hard
and
when your body begins to seize up on you
and freeze on you and shut down on you
you're gonna feel it you're gonna feel
it and go
we used to not be safe and now we are
we used to not be safe
well now we are
and we're just gonna practice safety
when you don't feel safe when your
wife's dragging you into a fight with an
older woman in a gas station you are
right to say this is not smart for
either of us let's not do this I brought
you back inside I thought we could talk
it out I was stupid of me I'm sorry
you're a good man dude you're a good man
you've been through hell and back and
you got the scars and strength to prove
it
[Music]
let's make moving forward about
Connections make moving forward about
safety let's make moving forward about
teaching our body that we weren't okay
then but we're okay now
let's break this generational abuse and
alcohol let's stop it stops with you
I'll walk with you the whole way my
brother give me a call anytime we'll be
right back
[Music]
I've got a word from our sponsor better
help listen I've been on both ends of
therapy in my life I've gotten it myself
and I've walked people through it and
I've seen the benefits from both sides
when someone owns their past and the
cracks in their armor but here's the
deal Getting to Know Yourself is not a
one-time event acknowledging the stories
that make you who you are can be a
lifelong process and talking through
things with the right sounding board
empowers you to change your future and
be the best version of yourself so if
you're thinking about starting therapy I
recommend better help better help
connect you with a licensed therapist
who can walk with you on that journey of
self-discovery and it's a hundred
percent online and it's designed to be
convenient flexible and work for your
schedule just fill out a quick
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and if it's not the
right fit you can switch therapists at
any time for no additional charge visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com
deloney
all right we are back let's go to Darby
in Buckeye Arizona what's up Darby
hi John thanks for taking my call of
course what's up
um I just had some questions about how
to talk to my grandkids about their
mother
um choosing drugs and being homeless
instead of
um taking care of them
yikes that's tough
it is tough
are you Grandma
I am yes
what happened in your daughter's life
that made drugs
the best solution that she feels like
will get her through her day
she said I can think of because I've
thought about this a lot
of
um biological father
just kind of
really didn't want a whole lot to do
with her
more so
um just kind of
you know she would go for a visit but
didn't really do much with her you all
divorced
yes
long ago when she was
nine months old is when her dad left was
your pregnancy pretty traumatic pretty
stressful
oh very much
very much
and that's the that's the biggest thing
that I can think of and then she had
gone through
um
some troubles with I I remarried when
she was five and we're still married
today
and we had a problem with my husband's
brother
and
he was inappropriately touching her
so we had to go through that whole thing
and she did some counseling
but she's just kind of always Darby
always looking Harvey Darby Darby
that's not kind of a problem with my
husband's brother
yeah it was a
was it it was and we we definitely
didn't
sleep it under the rug I mean we talked
about it and we did some counseling
but um
that's like saying Darby that's like
saying a bomb went off and we didn't
just leave it we like cleaned up some of
the glass
that type of ah man
so where's her where's baby's parent dad
um my granddaughter the oldest one her
dad is in North Dakota
okay well they're both in North Dakota
but my grandson's never met his dad
he's never been a part of his life why
not
um I've never met him
my daughter had moved to North Dakota
um when she turned 18.
and that's when she met my
granddaughter's father why'd she moved
all the way to North Dakota
my oldest daughter lived there and she
just wanted to be on her own
sort of on her own well not at my house
so she moved there
and
um so there was I don't know exactly
everything that was going on while she
was away
and so she had my granddaughter
and then
um it didn't work out with her
my granddaughter's father
and she met this guy I have never met
him
didn't know him very long they got
married she didn't even tell me
and then next thing I know
she left him she's pregnant
and
um just not doing well so we
went back to North we drove over to
North Dakota and brought her back
we were living in Washington state at
the time
and she had the baby in Washington and
lived with us
but yeah we've never met
met his dad
so I think it's really important from
right now until the rest of your life is
is through
for you to never
say
my daughter is choosing drugs over
babies
it looks like that and for you and me
who are not struggling with addiction
that that algorithm makes sense on paper
but there is a hurt inside of her and a
disconnection and a pain that is so
profound
that the only thing
I I'm trying to think of something
minuscule like a time that my tooth
snapped in half
um and a root canal I had broke and I
had two exposed nerves
and I couldn't I couldn't see it hurts
it was pain that was in the ball of my
foot all the way through my body
and I went in my room and I shut the
door and I put my face down and I had
like a warm thing on my face and my
mouth was swelling up
and when my son I was like get out of my
room get out of here I can't I got the
pain was so intense volume words
anything
that's inside her soul
mm-hmm
so it's not a matter of her waking up
and being like you know what screw those
kids I'm getting high
this is not how that works
I've never in my life met an addict that
was like no dude I absolutely hate my
kids I love the state of my life right
now
I would much rather be homeless
than have a warm safe place to stay and
be with my kids
I've never met that person ever
so if I'm telling a nine and a
six-year-old this I'm telling little
kids this
I'm telling a mommy is really really
sick
that's kind of what I've been telling
my granddaughter
for the past three years that she hasn't
seen her mom yes that's it mommy's
really sick right now and she loves you
very much but right now
she she doesn't love herself and she's
just really sick I wouldn't even say
that and because listen part of your
your those little kids know that half of
them is Mom
and so any negativity to those kids
is negativity directly into their their
little Souls
Amy's really really sick
where is she now
she's in Phoenix
okay
yeah she
she went to rehab
um in March of 2020
but she um
she got caught with
with um drugs on her possession so they
they kicked her out
very very common what kind of drugs is
she using
what's her drug I'm not exactly sure she
just says pills okay yeah
so it's been kind of a
a roller coaster of it for definitely
for the last three years
and I just can I ask you a devastating
hard question
what was that I ask you like it's a
devastatingly hard question and I don't
mean this to be ugly I'm I'm asking this
for facts okay
instead of saying why is she choosing
drugs over her kids
why would she choose homelessness over
your house
what is it about your relationship and
her relationship with your husband
that is less safe than being on the
street
I would love to ask her that question
would you be able to hear the answer
of course I would definitely hear the
answer
even if it hurt real bad
oh yeah okay
it's very very common especially if
she's into opiates it's very common for
her to take multiple rehab stents
opiates work I've Been Told opiates are
um if that if you know when someone
tells me they're all peeled out that's
usually what it means
they are chemically very similar to love
okay
and man that's somebody who's in
Desperate desperate need of connection
and it's really really hard to stay
connected to an addict someone who's
struggling with addiction I know that I
know that I know it personally it's hard
and there's seasons of
like I I can't be I'm choosing to keep
myself safe I'm choosing my boundaries
and I'm choosing my relationships
um safety here I'm going to create some
space
the route I've taken in my life is there
will never be a moment that you go to
sleep that you don't know that I love
you
and when you're ready I'm ready
yeah and I'll hear from
her every now and then mostly
um I'll hear from her boyfriend's mother
which we got in contact with each other
ask her we've discovered that we were
there
so let me just say this way that plan
isn't working
no but it's the only way I know
what what's going
her would she meet you for breakfast
once a month no she won't she won't meet
me we've tried that and she doesn't show
up she says she's going to
and she doesn't show up okay I saw her
one time
um I got a hold of her
because her number always changes so
what works today will not work the next
time of course
and I met her with some it was right
after Thanksgiving
and I met her with some you know I told
her hey I want I have some Thanksgiving
dinner for you and she was excited and
we met at a park
and
you know I tell her you know I love you
so much and I'm here for you
whenever you want to talk you can call
me we can meet and we can I'll take you
to dinner
you know you can't come to the house
because I and I don't know if I'm doing
the right thing but
I haven't allowed her
to see the kids since she left because
she's
she's not okay yeah and I don't want her
coming and going out of their life
especially my granddaughter my grandson
he really
doesn't remember her a whole lot yeah
but his body does his body does
he's he's kind of a different kid he's
got a lot of
right his body his body a lot of issues
yes yes here's the here's the deal
um
there's so many complex factors here
when we tell somebody who's really
struggling really really struggling
let's let's take
um
let's say that your daughter's throwing
up she's barfing everywhere
and
she finally comes in in and you all meet
at the foot of her bed and you say hey
you're only allowed in here when you're
through barfing
so you stay in here don't come out and
when you're done barfing I'll be ready
for you
Emma close the door
it keeps barf off of everything it does
but it makes the work of relational
reconnection her problem the person
who's sick makes it their problem
and maybe it's not safe for you to crawl
into bed with her
but maybe
again everything you've tried so far is
not working
what if you just decided once a month or
once every two weeks I'm driving over to
the local IHOP and I'm just gonna sit
there I'm gonna text her and let her
know hey I'm here for our our breakfast
7 30. and go ahead and take a book and
some work because she's probably not
going to show
and then show up the next week
and then show up the week after that
and maybe you're just going to get a
whole bunch of work done and get some
books read that'd be cool
maybe one time she shows up
and you're not going to be there with
your advice and your lectures she's got
enough shame she knows she knows
there's not a thing you're gonna say and
she's gonna go ah I didn't know that
but Lego piece by Lego piece maybe her
body begins to feel safe
and maybe Darby none of this works
I don't know I got a daughter
and I just know I would storm the gates
of hell for that little girl
I also know loving somebody who's
struggling struggling with addiction is
a nightmare I know that
so I'm gonna keep showing up I'm gonna
keep myself safe keep myself in in my
boundaries I'm gonna keep showing up I'm
gonna keep showing up
not with my lectures not with my advice
but with pancakes
and an open heart
[Music]
and maybe
she'll come too
[Music]
she's not choosing drugs over her kids
she's trying to stay alive the only
broken crooked way she knows how until
she learns another way
it's going to be a long cycle
if you can bridge that Gap
for the shot
thanks for the call we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here I feel
like I fell through a glitch in The
Matrix this is my job I get to have this
show do this show walk alongside each
one of you as a career this is what I do
and I have a blast doing it and me and
the team were so thankful for all of you
for being a part of our show whether
you're one of the original 17 or you're
one of the millions that's come since
then we are so grateful for you and we
want to put together the best possible
show that we can so if you're one of The
Originals or if you're brand new we want
your feedback tell us what you love
about the show what you hate about the
show would you like to see more of what
you like to hear more of and what you
want us to never do again you can email
us at askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's
ask John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right we are back let's go out to
Memphis Tennessee right down the road
from me and talk to Lexi what's up Lexi
hi Dr John what are you today I'm
partying what's up oh man I'm really
excited to talk to you I'm one of the
original 17 who's been listening since
episode one yes way to go I'm so happy
that you are still with us I think we're
down to 12. but I'm glad you're still
here yeah yeah well I'm super excited to
be here um I have hopefully a a little
bit chill question for you today we this
episode desperately needs a chill
question hey can you uh make sure you
talk directly into your phone okay okay
yeah can you hear me now perfect yes
okay so my question today is how can I
help support my partner my husband who
is struggling with ADHD
um and also get the support and help
that I need to
are you my wife
I thought you might say
uh no but she always threatens to call
the show and be like hey I love a guy
who has a marriage show but how do I get
him to take the trash out so
yeah I I thought you might say something
like that based on you know listening
for a while what is ADHD how does it
manifest in your house what are you what
are you tired of
um so my husband is awesome he's
creative and fun and a really good dad
um but he does
tend to be forgetful
um of things or they're easily
distracted or overwhelmed
um and I know you always say to lead
with us we have a 10 month old baby okay
and so some of the things in the past
that I've been able to catch
um I can't because I'm also managing a
baby
um and it's it's little things that add
up to big things you know like hey you
know we both work full-time outside of
the home and we've got a division of
these are the things he's in charge of
these are the things I'm in charge of
and some of them he does really great
but then the trash only gets to the curb
like once a month
um and that's a little thing you know
but it does add up over time where I end
up feeling like I have to be
on like hey did this get done did this
get done to get biscuit done oh my gosh
it's happening it's happening I can tell
you know you know what I'm about to say
right
um maybe you are becoming the mother of
two
right and I don't want that I
desperately don't want that but you are
you are yeah and so how do you know he
has ADHD
um so he was diagnosed as a kid and then
he had an evaluation as an adult where
he was diagnosed um I actually didn't
find out he had ADHD and so we had been
married for more than a year because he
forgot
no he didn't yeah he didn't no he didn't
listen if you Google ADHD my picture
comes up we don't forget we just think
that this time it will be it will be
different yeah and honestly
much of an issue
an ish I'm struggling with it right now
right correct our life is more chaotic
we have a small baby we became
homeowners our house needs work like I
understand why it's it's flared up now
but I don't want to be a mom of two I
want to be a supportive partner but also
um doesn't become resentful okay
so you know this I'm just going to run
through this for the audience grown men
myself included with ADD ADHD act like
children a lot
um and the women in our lives become
they act like our moms
and then when people with ADHD feel
controlled they have one response and
that's explode they lash out or they run
away right like a child does right and
no Mom wants to sleep with her son and
vice versa so you get in this weird trap
of the only thing that helps ADHD is
connection and the only thing that
begins to slowly nobody wants to sleep
with a guy I don't know what time it is
or hey let's have sex at eight o'clock
tonight and it's 8 45 and he's just
getting into the chat like whatever
right you you know that whole Loop
um and what's what's my joke like I will
get in the shower at 7 58 and um
for an eight o'clock meeting that is 30
minutes away from my house and I'll get
out of the shower at 8 15 and be pissed
that I'm late like like it just happened
right
ah jeez
um okay so a couple of for for just the
general audience poor self-regulation
um extra sensitivity to environment to
um psychology to nutrition these kind of
things time my wife calls it my magic
time
mm-hmm
just magic time just like oh yeah I'll
get those uh the trash and I'll get in a
second in a second is it's about a
30-day buffer of the second right
it's between now and October it'll it'll
get done and here's the other thing
that's annoying it usually gets done
just not in the picture that the you you
guys you guys agreed on right
uh the uh the the handicapped parking
spot
it's just a second I'll just pull right
in there just a second that the rules
apply to everybody except for me right
yeah sometimes okay exactly
yeah they applied it to everybody but me
except when they apply to me all right
here's the path forward and let me tell
you this the encouragement side is on
the other side of this
um I've made some extraordinary heavy
Headway no medication just I've made
some extraordinary Headway okay
are you ready for what I'm gonna say I
am you're not gonna like it I know
the first thing and most important thing
is your husband has to want to change
yeah
he has to want this to be different not
because you're nagging him
but he wants to have to he has to choose
a more peaceful life and for somebody an
adult with ADHD especially a successful
adult with ADHD it feels like you're
giving up your superpower
it feels like if I'm not always a little
bit late a little bit by the seat of my
pants a little bit over prepared I don't
have that adrenaline push and it feels
like I'm not my best self and that's a
just it's a lie it's not true
but I have to feel like I'm letting I'm
setting the sword down a little bit and
that's scary
yeah and he's expressed that like it's
becoming frustrating to him there we go
okay that's it
he's looking for resources he told me he
was like I was listening to this book
about managing your ADHD as an adult and
the first thing they said was pay
attention and it made me want to throw
the book listen there's only one book to
read that's it one book and it's by
Gabor mate m-a-t-e in the book is called
scattered that's it that's a book you'll
need to read together it's a very hard
book to read because he traces ADHD all
the way back to maternal stress
yeah and that honestly would make sense
here ADHD is a learned response a body's
response to chaos and yes there may be
some genetic components there may be
some X and y's and Z but it is a body's
learned response to chaos the Gabor mate
goes Dr mate does a great job he
expresses attention like a traffic cop
at an a busy intersection and the cars
are coming the cars are coming and in a
person with ADHD the cars are all
driving the same speed it's just that
the traffic cop is asleep on the grass
and you gotta get you gotta decide I'm
gonna wake this person up to the direct
traffic otherwise the traffic just gets
all the decisions got to be made
everything gets piled up and you throw a
10 month on top of that and then normal
marriage issues that come from having a
10 month old in the house and a new
house and a mortgage and all that [__]
that traffic cop is like dude I'm taking
four Xanax I'm out right you're just
gonna I'm gonna pass out on the side of
the road right so you got to get that
book
you can't be his mom you got to be his
wife
yeah and that means you all need to sit
down together and choose your battles
here's what I mean
sometimes the fact that the dishwasher
is is filled up
and it's not filled up like you would do
it those are two separate things
sometimes my wife and I pack different
suitcases when we travel because the way
I pack my suitcase makes my wife want to
set her hair on fire just to feel pain
just to feel something and she does it
in such an orderly fashion it's amazing
when she opens it up I've watched her do
it and I've tried to duplicate it and it
just I can't do it but
we both are going to get our bags packed
and we're both going to go to the same
vacation have a great time and she's
learned to open her hands on
this just the suitcase is going to look
differently and I've learned I've got to
have my bag packed the night before
because it makes my wife feel safe
well it needs to be written down in a
very direct conversation because often
moms talk to their kids in very circular
manners
and so I want the language for you to be
not things that annoy you this is what
makes me feel safe and this is what
makes me feel loved
when you are on time it makes me feel
like you see me and you love me
when you are late it makes me feel like
you are disrespecting me and you that
your time is more valuable than my time
that was the conversation that changed
my life
yeah that that sounds
like it would be really helpful and we
started to have some of those
conversations but they can't be
conversations because ADHD people
experience emotions in a heightened
sense in the emotional regulation takes
over and it becomes the greatest
conversation we've ever had and the sex
afterwards is amazing and then I forgot
everything we talked about
okay
right
yeah you're like crap are you in my
house yes I am in your house so you
gotta write this down and you'll have to
have a needs and wants dinner time
make it a romantic date
and then he's gonna have to learn to
parent himself what do I mean by that
here's a couple of things that really
impact ADHD and adult people
chaos in the house lots of clutter lots
of stuff
my wife likes knickknacks and stuff like
that she has conceded and she has been
really gracious in getting rid of a lot
of that stuff and in some ways in some
parts of our house it's almost
minimalist other parts it's pretty
chaotic
um but in some parts
um it's very minimalist it's peaceful
and allows a over stimulated brain to
slow down a little bit okay also eating
right in exercise is huge for the adult
with ADHD
huge I cannot miss a day
period
in my whole team everybody in the team
knows now if they walk by my desk or
they come to ask me something I'm eating
a bag of gummy candy they all just know
oh well he's off the off the wagon
and there's a there's a ripple effect
and so here's the sentence you've
probably heard me say this on the show
before here's the sentence that my wife
gives me here's a sentence I give myself
don't forget to remember that's just the
gentle sentence she gives me
when I'm when I am coming away from a
pizza buffet and I'm on round three and
I've got them piled up really high she
will just gently put her skin on my skin
she'll touch her my her hand on my arm
and she'll say don't forget to remember
how you're gonna feel tomorrow morning
that's it she doesn't say oh my gosh
you're getting fatter Are you seriously
gonna eat all that she didn't see any of
that because I'm overly sensitive I feel
it really heavy when she says that
she just simply puts her hand on my arm
and says don't forget how you're gonna
feel tomorrow and I always go oh God I
feel terrible
and now I'm going to set this thing down
see what I'm saying
yeah for sure and I think we've in the
past we've been better without you know
having a new baby has definitely turned
King Paul I think one thing relative to
that that I've struggled with is it's
very All or Nothing
it's either I have to be up at 5am every
day to do my workout or I'm not going to
get up any days
yup yeah and as a partner for that it's
a little bit like okay what version of
You Are you this week
ah I think you are my wife I think you
are
yes yes
and
um I'll tell you another book that was
revolutionary for me and it is not a
mental health book and I told him I told
him to his face uh the book discipline
equals Freedom by Jocko willing
it's written in gigantic font
like a like a military Field Manual
you can read the whole book in an
afternoon
but it's very very clear and it was the
first book I ever read that basically
said you can live a life of misery and
Chaos forever
or you can begin to flatten out your
life a little bit and do the same things
over and over again regardless of how
you feel regardless of how tired you
think you are always discipline is the
path and discipline has such a bad
connotation right all it means is I
don't care how I feel I'm just going to
get up at the same time every day I
don't care quote-unquote how I feel I'm
going to do some sort of exercise
downstairs period there is not a
discussion about this
and again for for me my wife is conceded
on half the garage as a gym
a big a big nice gym we spend a lot of
money on because if I had to get in the
car and drive I missed a lot
yeah we're working on getting our home
gym set up fantastic partly for that
reason yeah that's that's that is him
learning to parent himself
and every parent has to apparent their
kid differently because every kid's
different
the big thing is is you shifting from
over him to with him
I'm with you on this and if you're late
and you get fired I can't I'm not I'm
not going to tell you you got to be at
work
I'm not gonna tell you that you know you
got to be at work you're an adult
and those are really really hard
and being honest with him enough to say
I get really scared when you're late
because I think you're gonna get fired
and then we're not gonna have a house
I think that that all makes sense and
but it's so hard I know it's so hard to
know
it's definitely one of those things
where
we try really hard and I think we think
we've done fairly well with this to to
look at things of like the two of us
versus a problem instead of US versus
each other and so I think reading these
books together and you know talking
through this is helpful because we had a
conversation the other day where I was
just like look
I am realizing that you view the entire
world differently than I do
um it's not a matter of you it's a
matter of experience okay
like it feels incredibly insulting to me
to be in a meeting like I feel it in my
body
when I'm in a meeting and I gotta go
because I got another meeting
I feel wrong it feels wrong to stand up
and be like hey I gotta go let's finish
this conversation later I feel terrible
like it I can't describe it other than
it hurts like it's just like gosh what a
jerk mm-hmm so I stay 15 minutes later
in the meeting
and I want to make sure we have the
conversation I'm honoring you with your
time I'm listening I'm paying attention
and then we go to the next meeting I'm
15 minutes late and that person feels
completely like I've wasted their day
like right I've totally ignored them and
made them late see what I'm saying so I
it's not a matter of seeing the world
differently it's a matter of feeling the
world differently
okay and what I have to feel is when you
do this it hurts my wife
when you do this the kids feel like this
and I don't I don't want to hurt my wife
I don't hurt my kids and more
importantly now that I've had a taste of
what peace feels like I want that
and I literally don't see the plastic
cups in my car my coffee mugs in my car
when I'm getting out I don't see them
I'm too busy thinking about something
else like a song I used to sing in front
of the mirror when I was in fourth grade
and oh yeah remember that girl and I
wonder what happened to that girl
because I thought I was gonna marry her
I think she married my friend you know
what my friend did one time he and I'm
off to the races and as I'm getting out
of my car I remember don't forget to
remember how good it feels to get into a
clean car and I stop and then I look and
I'm like I need to get these 14 coffee
mugs out of here
and then I bring him up and my wife used
to be like are you kidding me you have
freaking coffee mug and now she goes
thank you for bringing these in
a short circuits my shame spiral and it
short circuits the whole thing and it
just we can move on
and when I have seasons of bad ADHD when
I'm spinning I'm just turning my wheels
and I'm carrying a bag of donuts with me
everywhere I don't carry Donuts but what
uh I'm over exaggerating but there's
Seasons when she knows
my wife graciously says not when are you
gonna get the trash out that's not how
she approaches me she does approach me
with
hey some of the signs are pointing to
you're not doing okay
how can I love you better right now
and then I usually drop my shoulders and
say I'm really tired I'm really scared
I'm not gonna hit this book deadline or
whatever's coming up and I we have a
conversation that we can talk and that
usually resets me
does that make sense it does it
and I think to
to what I'm hearing and what I think is
important is the answer is not just
don't have needs and manage everything
the answer is continue to
engage in the relationship and say hey
these are
these are the ways that
you know this is impacting me and and
you're an adult and so
um you're gonna choose different things
or you're gonna do what you do and I'm
here to support you in making good
choices for yourself and
um ADHD is a context not an excuse and
most of the time in my life ADHD choices
are not made in the moment they're made
30 minutes or an hour or two hours or
five hours before
okay my cell phone has to stay off and
in my bag
period otherwise I choose to pick it up
and then I choose to scroll forever and
then I'm choosing to be late and I
didn't choose to be late I just chose to
check my Instagram stuff real quick
so the choice to be on time is the
choice to keep my bag my phone in the
bag
yeah see what I'm saying so it's it's
just learning a new context
um you said something I want to touch on
before right before we leave you said I
know it's not us
we're not fighting each other we're
fighting the problem
I want to change that language with ADHD
because he that is part of him
yeah and if you end up fighting we're
just fighting the ADHD
whether you say we're gonna be on the
same side of the table or not you're
both fighting him and he's going to
start he's going to go to war with
himself he's going to declare a civil
war on himself and and that's that's
what ADHD does and nobody wins
I want the whole conversation to change
to how do we have a peaceful home
and how do I best love you so that you
can best love me how do I help meet your
needs so that you are fully able to help
meet my needs and that means you're
gonna have to be really explicit about
what your needs are and you probably
have to spend some time with yourself
because right now it just feels like if
you just did diapers and just did dinner
and just did this then I would have ah
that would work for a little bit and
feel good for a little bit
but there's going to be something
different I need you to plug in and be a
part of this family what are the things
he needs to do to be fully plugged in
sometimes that means leave the phone in
the car sometimes that means don't open
your laptop when we're talking sometimes
that means
um Saturday mornings are exclusive there
is nothing planned on Saturday mornings
because that's when we go on long walks
and we talk together you gotta exercise
and in fact I'm gonna do morning time
because you've got to get in the gym and
exercise because that makes the whole
day better whatever those things look
like we're gonna create a life worth
living together we're going to create
amazing life
with the ADHD not in spite of it and
I'll say I think it's my superpower I
wouldn't trade it for the world I wish
I'd learned to manage it a lot better
earlier but I would trade it for
anything thank you so much for the call
Lexi he's lucky to have you lucky to
have you have fun on the adventure call
me anytime we'll be right back
[Music]
it seems
but most of us way undervalue real
genuine relationships our friendships
our marriages we don't know what we're
doing and instead of diving into the
mess we accept shallowness and
distraction and we wallpaper over our
loneliness so let me say this boldly you
cannot be well alone you've got to get
connected to real life people and have
deep powerful relationships I'm talking
about relationships where you can be
honest where you can open up where you
can share hard things and you each know
that you'll still show up for each other
and in my new book own your past change
your future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
here at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show man
that was a heavy one and some of those
calls took a long time
um thanks for hanging with us and for
being a part of this show
if you've made it this far
shout out to The One and Only
lives right down the road here the Great
t-swift
the great t-swift and if you're like oh
my gosh are you seriously doing yep
songs called Bad Blood
and it goes like this
baby now we got bad blood you know it
used to be mad love
so take a look at what you've done
because baby now we've got bad blood
ready for the poem
do you have to do this I was thinking
you could be trusted did you have to
ruin what was shiny now let's all rusty
did you have to hit me where I'm weak
maybe I couldn't breathe and rub it in
so deep salt in the wound like you're
laughing right at me
now we got problems
I don't think we can solve them
you can't check out the hook while the
DJ revolves them that was my Vanilla Ice
what's up you made a really deep cut and
baby
now we got bad blood
[Music]
if that doesn't move you then you should
probably go see somebody call better
help hey this is the Delaney show we'll
talk to you soon
foreign